you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum how are you today i
hope you're i thank you for
choosing our podcast
the little podcast to uh
start your week or maybe it's the end of
your week and you're listening to it i
really don't know but i really
appreciate you taking the time out to
listen and i know some people are here
from misha collins and i hope that after
the episode you're like you know i dug
that i want to stick around i'm gonna
subscribe to this guy's podcast give it
a chance because i think a lot of times
people come ryan for the guest yeah i
would say that's true for a lot of
podcasts yeah
i'm here to listen to misha collins not
michael rosenbaum which is fair but
maybe he's a gateway drug for a lot of
people to get into the podcast there you
go
yeah i agree
i just did an audition and i'm still
talking like that
i don't know uh you know if you want to
follow us you can follow us on twitter
at insidetou at inciteepod and instagram
and facebook at insideeapodcast
i appreciate it you can write reviews on
spotify apple
wherever
watch the uh episode on youtube if you
like you can watch the entire episode we
also have clips and things like that so
i appreciate you doing that and
appreciate you uh
supporting the podcast
today um ryan's have a good week
yeah yeah you're busy this week i'm busy
this week you are busy i got a lot of
things going on this week in fact i'm
supposed to interview jared padalecki
and i gotta figure out who's gonna be my
engineer for that i know i cannot be
here before i cannot be here for it so
hopefully we'll get jason my sweet
editor to uh to be part of that if he
has time you know because jared's a busy
guy if we don't get him we may not get
him again for a while hopefully it
doesn't flake
well he's not really a flake i mean he
hasn't flaked on me before
uh what else uh if you want to go to the
inside of you online store you can get
great merch like autographed lunchbox
small lunchboxes from me and tom and we
autographed those or just an autographed
lunchbox from me autographed scripts
sign pictures mugs tumblers shirts
so many so much great stuff on the uh
inside of you online store
and also if you want to go to
sunspin.com that's my band it's called
sunspinsunspin.com
you can get band merch you can book me
for a zoom if you want to zoom with me
i'm also on the cameo and uh yes uh
that's that's really about it misha
collins is the guest today uh we talk
about a lot of stuff
we uh you know he's just he's a really
good guy
um it was nice having him here in the
studio was wasn't it nice it's just so
much nicer when i had jensen here i had
misha
um
and he's got a good he's got a good
microphone voice too he does he's got a
really
infectious rich it's rich it's deep it's
gravely it is it's accented and people
love this guy yeah people love misha i
think he's got a heart of gold too and
uh you know let's just do it let's uh
i'm reminding you now to after the
podcast is over uh please
subscribe and do all that stuff if
you're here for misha also join patreon
patreon.com inside of you you could join
patron uh become a patron and support
the podcast in other ways the podcast
needs your help so if you want to become
a patreon i always message you after you
become a patron i ever sent a message
saying thank you so go to patreon
p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot com slash inside of
you and without further ado let's get
inside of misha collins it's my point of
view
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
you know misha i always feel like
the guest is going to get up and walk
out
i i i might get up and walk out at any
moment please don't um i always feel
it's it's nice to see you it's nice to
see you it is nice to see you in person
the last time we did this it was uh a
zoom it was a virtual experience yeah
and don't you feel like those are kind
of not they're impersonal or they're
just you feel like there's not as much
of a connection
yeah it's nice you get to shield
yourself from actually being known by
the other person in this industry it's
always like what are you doing and
people are like oh i'm doing this and i
got this script going on and i got you
know and i got this one show and i'm
doing a food show and i'm doing you've
got all these things going on
but there's something really brave and
cool to just go
i don't have [ __ ] going on right now i'm
taking care of me i'm taking care of
myself i want to get i want to feel good
because i read somewhere that you know
towards the end of supernatural like you
hit a [ __ ] wall
like you know i to quote you it was
something like you were deeply fried i
don't know if you said that but uh and
the net effect of that was that you were
really you weren't really loving
anything dreading everything is this
true i don't know about dreading
everything but i i was i mean i think
the colloquial term is burnt out um
it was
we uh we were doing a breakneck
schedule of
fan conventions and shooting on
supernatural
and i was living in washington state and
driving across the border so my commute
was you know
some some mornings it was an hour and a
half in the car just to get to work and
and then i'd be driving home at three
o'clock in the morning you know and
crossing the border and
i um i was exhausted i was also you know
running a non-profit and or not running
a nonprofit but i was you know
board president of a non-profit that i
had started and i was you know uh doing
these scavenger hunts and the cons and
the conventions and uh and other you
know businesses and working on writing
projects i had so much work that i was
doing that i
uh
that it became difficult to enjoy any of
the work if i'm being honest like i
didn't have i wasn't well resourced
enough
to
be happy at that point and
um and it just wasn't sustainable but at
the same time like i i definitely was
running on the fumes to an extent um and
the cortisol kept me going and i think
that that even has an addictive property
at least it does for me like working
you know they call it workaholism for a
reason are you a workaholic i can be i
can get into a pattern of if i don't
know what to do with myself i'll work
and
that can be a treadmill that's hard to
get off of for me at times
so um
yeah
yeah that's tough i remember doing
smallville and i i remember just
being absolutely exhausted by episode
like 19 of 23 or 20 whatever episodes we
did and
we we drove ourselves for quite some
time
and um and as did you you guys drove
yourselves but
i remember one location was over an hour
away it was always raining jared and
jensen never drove themselves they never
did could you have had a driver or they
just weren't going to give you a drink
after 12 years after eight year after
five years oh no no no you know it's
funny you as soon as you become a son of
a [ __ ] they should have stuck up for
you
as soon as you become a regular you lose
your driver it's kind of ironic right
guest stars get drivers but but it was a
good thing you would take that exchange
yeah for sure
i mean but i remember driving and with
one eye closed and i was just really
depressed i was just down and not to
knock canada i love canada i love
canadians i love vancouver but vancouver
rains a lot and it gets depressing and i
remember this one time i'm just
listening to this depressing song and i
felt like chris farley the guy was like
i'm gonna drive the goddamn car off the
road i just felt like i really was i had
to pull over and just like get my
bearings
because i was really like
just physically and emotionally
exhausted i was done and i was there two
hours before everybody shaved in the
head i just remembered that one time
going holy [ __ ] dude you've lost your
mind you're gonna be one of those actors
that they write about
not for very long just for like maybe
the day that's the thing on twitter
someone dies unfortunately and it's just
like oh my god oh and then the next day
you're you know
what the [ __ ] is that right where was i
going with this but you were burnt out
you know i mean i think that that is you
know it's it's funny i mean it's not
funny um it is it is a you know everyone
says
it's it's not as glamorous as you think
or whatever there are so many aspects of
of the job working as an actor that are
amazing amazing and it's
and there's so many like pinch me
moments right where you can't believe
the good fortune that you have
and you
and you also have to remind yourself to
be grateful for the good fortune that
you have but
but the fact of the matter is you also
are quite often working until three
o'clock in the morning or four o'clock
in the morning and then driving yourself
home or what we would do often is work
until three o'clock in the morning on a
friday and drive to the airport and just
wait for the 6am flight to get to the
east coast to do a convention and it was
like you're not your body doesn't your
body can't and the older you get you can
do it when you're in your 20s early 30s
you start to hit your 40s late 40s like
me i'm almost 50.
it's amazing how those things just your
body goes no way no thank you no i'm not
i'm not doing that you're not doing that
you're not getting on another plane
and you have to listen to your body
because
with me i just know that if i'm
exhausted or emotionally i mean that's
when the anxiety kicks in
and there's nothing worse than having
anxiety on attack on set have you ever
had an anxiety attack on set no
what's that like [ __ ] have you have you
heard
where it it debilitated you or
debilitating i was i was the lead on
this serious short-lived show last
couple seasons called him pastor and i
remember being
i remember doing a lot of push-ups right
before the take and i had to run across
and talk to the uh
this other pastor in the scene and i ran
across and i'm looking at him
and my whole body started to get kind of
numb
and my heartbeat was kind of racing
and i go
i'm gonna have a heart attack i didn't
say that ago
and i was just i think i knew my line so
well that nobody knew but i was freaking
the [ __ ] out as i'm giving these lines
and it happened to be lunch after that
take
and i thought oh my god what's going on
you know hey troy my assistant would get
get a doctor
and dr lim came on site you know oh yeah
i love dr lam dr lim oh he was the best
and he came on and goes um michael um
i'm checking everything everything seems
to be have you ever had
an anxiety attack
that's a great dr lim impersonation
does does dr lim know that you
impersonate him i didn't even mean to i
just tried
he speaks so quietly and so comforting
actually he is the the antidote to a
panic attack
just that voice is very soothing so you
know it could be um you could be having
a but hearing that was terrifying
because we had about three episodes left
and i go this is going to happen again
you're always anticipating it and it did
happen again in this final sequence
and i remember i was freaking out i
didn't want to tell anybody it's
embarrassing oh my god i can't be doing
this i'm the lead actor i can't have a
panic attack they're gonna sh you know
so i just go hey guys i gotta go to the
bathroom my stomach's bothered me
because i gotta really take a [ __ ] right
now i think i've told this story and and
the director's like hey can we just do
one more take and i go i go ah
i really need to go
and so i raced to my trailer and i went
in there and i'm like a drug addict
looking for my xanax looking for the
pills where are they just throwing
everything away my troy walks in the
assistant and is like you okay i'm like
no i'm having a panic attack i'm just
i'm numb i'm tingling in my arms and my
legs i'm just like it was just sheer
exhaustion it was a combination of not
sleeping
stress
and
whatever i i don't know being
overwhelmed and it just
it is a terrifying thing and i i refuse
to tell anybody i think now i'm in a
place where i would say hey guys i'm
having a little anxiety attack right now
i just want the crew to know i'm
hopefully going to get through it
but i'd like everybody to know so it's
not uh what the [ __ ] wrong with
rosenbaum this is what's wrong with him
i'm having anxiety attack and uh you
know trying to erase the stigma
and trying to show you that i'm a human
being and i've just uh i'm overwhelmed
right now
so if ever of course that would freak
everybody out right right he's like oh
my god he's lost his mind
so what do you do what would you do in
that situation i i i mean i think i've
i've dealt with anxiety on set i think
i've dealt with anxiety in auditions and
like test situations that was pretty
severe
um and difficult to get through the work
because of
um
but i've had i had panic attacks
probably about for a little stretch
about about 20 years ago and it is
almost impossible to describe because it
is so overwhelming and it feels so
physical you feel like you're going to
pass out well i i thought i was like you
i thought i was having a heart attack i
mean it seems like something in your
body is you something is radically wrong
it's not just like i'm anxious i'm
nervous which by the way anxiety
when it's when it's not a full-blown
panic attack can also be quite
debilitating but uh it's it feels
visceral it feels very physical
yeah
yeah i don't know i
uh
um
you you calling out to the crew and like
that's not a good idea letting them know
that you need a moment reminds me of one
of my early experiences with one of the
worst directors i was working on this
movie
that uh it was it was my first big role
in an independent feature this was
almost 20 years ago
and the director was he really didn't
know what he was doing but he thought
that he was scorsese and
it was my first day on set
and uh
and he
uh and we did one take and he comes up
to me and he he had this really kind of
creepy way of of talking to actors which
is he would he would whisper
conspiratorially in your ear as if what
he was saying was shameful
and so he comes up to me and he says ah
um misha um
are you all right you seem a little yeah
and i was like
what what
you don't say that too after the first
take on my first day on set so i and now
i'm thinking oh god why i've com like
i'm they're gonna fire me
this is horrible who is this guy and uh
and he says and i say yeah i think i'm
okay and he's like looks at me sort of
side eye like are you sure and i said
yeah
and he said okay okay all right everyone
we're going again
and i said wait wait um larry can you
just i'm sorry can you give me one
second and he said sure
and then he screams
everyone quiet on the set misha needs a
minute
this is the worst director in history
it was this cavalcade of
bad directing
and this probably made you freak out
even more of course it did yes so there
i was in the middle of my first scene on
the on having a little bit of first day
having a panic attack that was quite
in due in large part to the director's
bad direction
this podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy
everybody knows these guys
everybody loves them i love them ryan
it's great yeah yep it's helping you
getting a lot out of it amen
look folks relationships take work
especially the most important one you
can have in your life and that is your
relationship with yourself a lot of us
will drop anything to go help someone we
care about we'll go out of our way to
treat other people well but how often do
we give ourselves the same treatment
it's true we don't we're not good to
ourselves enough and you got to be good
to yourself and you'll learn how to be
good to yourself but one of those things
you could do is join uh better help this
month better help online therapy wants
to remind you that you matter just as
much as everyone else does and therapy
is a great way to make sure you show up
for yourself ryan what would you say
better help is doing for you
uh it is helping me to uh
learn
about myself better uh how to treat
myself better uh
and just talking about things that are
bothering me however big or small yeah
because sometimes you think oh i have
friends to talk with you i have
no you you can't be
absolutely open with your thoughts and
your demons and your thing just with
friends or you know people think they
take it it's so
easy you know like oh i don't need to
worry about that and it builds up and it
builds up and investors and
we all implode at some point
so we got to take care of ourselves and
better help online therapy is there to
help us better help is online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours give it a try and see why
over 2 million people have used better
help online therapy this podcast is
sponsored by better help and inside of
you listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
inside that's b e t t e r h e l p dot
com slash
inside
thank you better help
couldn't do it without you inside of you
is brought to you by neutral fall 80
million men ryan and women in the us
experience thinning hair
yes it's still not openly talked about
which can make going through it feel
scary stressful and and that just adds
to the problem doesn't it it does but
what if i were to tell you that
uh
this is normal
do you understand this is that millions
of americans experience thinning hair
and it's more than common it's it's
normal for people to experience this and
all in all ages i've seen it with my
friends i've seen them in their 20s
losing their hair i've seen people in
their 40s onwards
and there are things you can do
and neutral fall is here to help uh you
know
thinning hair is not openly talked about
so going through it can feel lonely
frustrating it's time to change the
conversation and join the thousands of
people standing up for their strands
with neutrophil neutrophil is the number
one dermatologist recommended hair
growth supplement clinically shown to
improve your hair growth thickness
invisible scalp coverage for men
and women you know that there are
multiple causes of thinning hair
neutrophil is the hair growth supplement
that goes beyond genetics to target
stress
hormones nutrition metabolism aging and
lifestyle factors that may be impacting
your hair thinning is different for men
and women neutrophil has multiple unique
formulas for men and women to provide
exactly what they need based on their
biology and age and every formula is
physician formulated using natural
medical grade ingredients for reliable
results without compromises
neutral fall is a simple addition to
your daily routine just four pills a day
and you'll begin to experience thicker
stronger faster growing hair in just
three to six months visit nutrafall.com
and take their hair wellness quiz it's
easy i could take it for god's sakes you
get a customized product recommendation
that puts the power to grow thicker
stronger hair back into your hands
in clinical studies 72 percent of men
some more scalp coverage and 86 percent
of women saw improved hair growth after
only six months neutrophil is also
trusted and recommended by 3 000 top
doctors more than 3 000 top doctors you
can grow thicker healthier hair and
support our show by going to
nutrafall.com and entering the promo
code inside to save fifteen dollars off
your first month's subscription this is
their best offer anywhere and it's only
available to us customers for a limited
time plus free shipping on every order
get fifteen dollars off at nutrafall.com
spelled n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com
promo code inside these statements have
not been evaluated by the food and drug
administration this product is not
intended to diagnose treat cure or
prevent any disease
do you ever have days where you feel
like an amateur like you can't get your
lines out you can't you you the nerves
start happening you've done this a
million times but all of a sudden you're
like why am i feeling this and you feel
like you're a newbie again and you just
want to take off to the moon or
something for some reason for me that
happens pretty much
every time i'm on scene really no no i'm
being hyperbolic but i um
i it does happen when when i've been off
for a while like when we would come back
on supernatural when we come back from a
hiatus and get back to work i'd be like
[ __ ] i forgot how to act what am i doing
i mean
you know you jump between you and me i
never really knew how to act but
um but it was like oh this is even worse
than usual so yeah for sure that's it oh
man yeah ryan you don't get panic
attacks really do you no i never had one
never never you don't want one i don't
want one well just know that if you're
having one it's probably not a heart
attack it's probably a panic attack yeah
you're gonna you're gonna
of course have a heart attack and be
like yeah it's it's probably a pain it's
just a panic attack i don't need to go
to the doctor
what arm is it by the way is it your
closest to your burnt toast you smell no
that's a stroke i think oh yeah but
isn't it like you're left
numb and your left arm the one closest
to your heart right
i don't remember i don't remember either
yep supernatural was in 2021
top streaming programs acquired it was
number seven on all the [ __ ]
streamers
i read that stat criminal minds was
number one and i didn't realize anyone
was watching that
i know it's amazing it's like a show
that's two shows that no one really
thinks about anymore but supernatural is
a huge show i mean you oh you said
something one time that it's not a
hollywood darling it's kind of under the
radar but it feels like every time i go
on twitter even now that the show's over
supernatural is trending mm-hmm one of
you guys is trending right every [ __ ]
day what is that about how well we are
constantly trying to create controversy
in order to stay relevant
um
so i'm we're we're doing a convention in
texas this weekend and we all plan to be
streaking
downtown in dallas uh just to get some
notoriety on twitter you're gonna just
get naked and do it um
uh yeah i don't know i mean i think
we've you know for whatever reason we
lucked into a really ardent fan base
that just
uh you know being a supernatural fan i
think has become kind of an identity and
um and how do you feel about that
well
uh at times it feels
amazing and at times it's kind of so
strangely surreal that it's almost
dissociative like i i don't even know
how to process it
i don't know yeah it's
it's also one of those things that i've
been you know it's been whatever 14
years now so i'm a bit endured to it it
just feels normal what do you think it
is about the show do you think it's just
like there's some kind of uh
it's almost like a cult maybe or a
um well i mean i guess there is a reason
that they use the phrase cult hit yeah
you know in a way right with the fans
i think that it's a combination of
factors one of them is that
uh
the show was on television for 15 years
and so the audience actually got to
watch these two characters jared and
jensen
that jared and jensen were playing
grow up as those actors grew up like you
see those the first season of that show
and they're kids yeah and
you know when the show ended they were
washed up
and
and so for an audience member who
actually started watching early on uh to
be able to carry through to the end of
the arc of the series they feel like
they've grown up with those characters
they've been in their home for so long
that they feel like family and the show
hits on um themes of family and i think
that that's a big
a big factor in it and i think another
factor is that our show came of age at
the same time that twitter came of age
like social media was just a burgeoning
yeah we were we were done right you
weren't around
so you didn't have that opportunity to
engage with your fans the way we did
we
happened i think because there wasn't
really a terribly solid template for us
to follow because it was really nascent
at that point
we didn't know what to do and so we were
kind of playful with the audience and we
have always been kind of playful with
the fans at the conventions in a way
that i think is a little bit
unconventional yeah pardon the use of
that term in this context
and um
and i think that that we weren't
terribly guarded with the fans we're a
little bit vulnerable we're a little bit
open a little bit open-hearted um we
were willing to you know make an ass to
yourself
make total asses of ourselves
humility i do the same thing with our
fans i just yeah i feel like because i
think i i was in were you a fanboy at
all before you became an actor like i
would go to some conventions like horror
conventions and like
dude that's the guy from uh evil dead 2
or that's the dude from dawn of the dead
man that's fly boy uh you know i'm going
to get his autograph i i was that guy
and then i fast forward all those years
and i'm i'm at the convention signing so
i always loved conventions were you like
that at all were you somebody who wanted
no i wasn't a dork you weren't
a dork like me did you want autographs
do you have autographs at your house um
i have a i i
when i was eight i wrote a letter to dr
seuss and he wrote back to me and i got
a signed photo from dr seuss
um i it's funny actually being around
these microphones in in a studio setting
reminds me of this but
i was a huge fan of public radio
national public radio i just nerded out
on i knew the names of all the hosts and
all the shows and when the shows were on
one local station
and i would listen to how old were you
when you were doing this this was like
you know starting early in high school
um when i was when i turned 18 uh my
girlfriend who later became my wife uh
got me a surprise birthday present and
it was like she was taking me somewhere
and i and we were in northern virginia
at the time and she said
uh i said well just tell me where you're
taking me she's like no i'm not gonna
spoil the surprise and i said come on
just just give me the address and she
said
okay fine it's 20 20 m street northwest
and i was like oh [ __ ] that's national
public radio headquarters i know that
like i was such a i was such a nerd and
so then for my birthday she took me and
to listen to the recording of uh an
episode of uh all things considered and
it was like this is all things
considered
is that what they say very good yeah
um but i so then i ended up interning at
national public radio headquarters and
uh and then working there briefly
uh when i was quite young
and walking around the halls and you
know he seeing the faces that were
connected to the voices that i knew so
well was
so thrilling to me um so that's where i
nerded out the most someone asked me
um
not too long ago maybe maybe
three years ago
um
if if i could have uh dinner with anyone
living who would it be and i said you
know what i think it would probably be
bob garfield who's a national public
radio personality who hosts this uh this
or he hosted this show
um called on the media which i loved um
but uh this was on stage at a convention
i answered that question and then two
days later i got a phone call and it was
bob garfield on the phone what my
twitter exploded who are you and now
we've become friends and it's like it's
very exciting what do you talk about
with him is there a lot to talk about we
talk about our personal lives we talk
about our our failings our shortcomings
uh our how old is he he's
i don't know i don't know how old bob
garfield is he's got to be 65.
how old are you bob are you listening
bob garfield i owe you a call by the way
bob i'm i'm gonna call you after this
podcast
uh you talked about this ad nauseam i
mean so many interviews but i think it's
pretty incredible that you know you come
up for a three guest star spot or
whatever and then all of a sudden you're
working 12 years on a show
were you i mean you must have been
really good you must have just fit right
the [ __ ] in
for them to make you a regular that
quick i well they didn't make me a
regular that quick it it it was by
degrees they we kept adding three more
episodes three more episodes and then
finally they were like all right it
looks like we're stuck with you um but i
didn't fit in i don't think i think it
was an interesting um mix where i was
actually
i was
somehow
i was a foil uh to
sam and dean's characters and and i was
different enough that it kind of
filled out the cast a little bit in a
way um that if i when i when i first uh
got on set i hadn't really watched the
show i was like a kind of lazy guest
star actor i was like i don't know
nobody watches you're like me that's
what i would do who cares i got i don't
know i'll be gone i'll be gone before
anyone even knows that i was here
and so uh i i knew that i was gonna be
playing an angel
and so i kind of showed up with this
very ethereal other earth you know
otherworldly quality and you added the
voice and i had the voice you know the
deep
voice for various reasons because i
thought that was going to be cool it
turned out it was a pain in the ass for
a long time but i um
i we did the first take and uh the
producer who was also the director the
executive producer director kim manners
uh came up to me and he said uh
can you try to do that again but not not
so spooky
and i was just like up i was the wrong
tone for the show altogether because all
of the characters that played demons or
witches or whatever they just came
across as real humans in the show at
that point and i was playing something
that was like spook spooky and
otherworldly because i didn't hadn't
watched the show
um but ultimately as that character got
tweaked and honed uh i i was a fish out
of water i didn't quite fit in but it
was actually in a weird way kind of what
the show needed at that point um
and
and i think you know obviously it worked
to an extent because they kept me there
for you know i watched outtakes i just
saw these outtakes and it just seems
like the whole time
jensen and jared are [ __ ] with you
that that is a fair characterization of
my experience i mean it's non-stop yeah
it's a it's abuse
it's abuse because didn't you have a lot
i mean you always had to say a bunch of
you had a lot of lines but i had plenty
of lines yeah plenty of lines and they
would uh incessantly [ __ ] with me
and you're trying to remember these
lines and they're [ __ ] or trying to
even just say them um yes um it was
it was maddening at times but it was
also
um i think
demonstrative of the fact that we had a
lot of fun on set like we left
i i think it it is probably
north of a million dollars in overtime
that warner brothers had to pay
for because of us walking around on set
over the years yeah but without
hyperbole i think that's probably is it
safe to say i mean like you probably
love these guys like brothers i mean but
you all three are extremely close
yeah it is you know it's funny i think
that um one of the one of the
interesting things about the
supernatural fandom is that they're all
of these factions like there are people
who consider themselves
sam fans and dean fans and jared fans
and misha fans
and a lot of times they butt heads there
are you know
small but vocal minorities of these of
the fandom that like the jared fans who
hate the misha fans or hate that i came
on the show at all and you know and you
have people that hate you yes and
and i but i think that they're also
small but vocal groups that think that
we actors don't get along or that you
know there's some feud going on between
me and jared or jared and jensen or
whatever and the fact of the matter is
we get along great and when we you know
hang up or end phone calls with one
another we always say love you brother
can't wait to see you i mean we're like
we really love and care for each other
um but there's this whole narrative
maybe it's maybe it's the sorry i keep
banging you're fine maybe it's the fans
um trying to
find a way to cultivate some additional
drama uh now but there really isn't any
drama to be said no you never had a day
where you're like oh my god [ __ ] off oh
no no we've all we
like like like people like life like
friends like friends and like you know
like siblings we have
all fought with one another at one point
or another and had like real knock-down
drag-out arguments really um you raised
your voice with each other yes certainly
but we also
uh but that's because we have like a
really close relationship and the
the overarching tenor of our friendships
is one of friendship and love for sure
what's the biggest fight that you could
recall on set that you were just like
[ __ ] off like the three you're just not
getting along or you're not getting
along with someone do you remember you i
always remember those moments when i
flipped out on willing i was directing
an episode and he was going
everything was going wrong the dolly
broke allison's clothing had a problem
uh
this window wasn't closing and he goes
and goes dude you're behind what the
[ __ ] and i go hey [ __ ] off kubrick
i'm doing my best here we got a lot of
problems outside dude chill
i'm just [ __ ] with you i'm like well
[ __ ]
going on right now you're trying to earn
respect here
and people are [ __ ] with you but
there's got to be a day that you can
remember that or maybe not no yeah i
mean there are times there were times
when um there was a time when uh
jared
i can't remember oh
yeah i mean we have
well here it comes ah jared
uh we were on a flight together and
jared uh took a photo of me like i i
failed to lock the door on the bathroom
in the in the airplane and jared noticed
and just opened the door and took a
picture of me on the toilet
and exposed
while i was on the toilet you know and i
grabbed his phone when i got back on the
plane and flushed it on the toilet
which precipitated a very unpleasant uh
fight between us but i was like wait a
minute you actually
flushed his toilet down the plain bath i
flushed his phone down the top the phone
yeah down the plain toilet that was that
was that's a big thing to do i know it
was a dick move now how upset was he he
was furious violent like he wanted he
wasn't violent but he was so pissed at
me that he wouldn't talk to me and and
he shouldn't i was i it was a completely
disproportionate response to what he had
done and yeah
and yet that was early on in our
that was early on on the show when we
would get into like pranking each other
and escalating things and sometimes
those things got to the point where it
was like this isn't funny anymore you
know one or the other of us would take
it a little bit too far
and that happened
mostly with between me and jared but
jensen did stuff too and i was like
really dude
really
and you just like [ __ ] off guys i need
to focus here or whatever i'll tell you
as we got older and um
i
and i think a little bit more mature
um we stopped doing that i think that
that are we're not like we're not
[ __ ] with each other like that
anymore right we're too old for this
nonsense well yeah actually i think do
you think so i think you think it just
got old after like season seven or eight
yeah yeah that's when it kind of that is
actually i think about when it
petered out really yeah do you miss it
no
you don't miss it no you know jared and
jensen got to keep that famous car what
was the car chevelle what was it uh
impala
chevy impala they both got one yeah did
they give you anything or were you
allowed to take anything home with you
did you take anything home with you i
have some i have some artifacts from the
show uh i don't have an impala but
i have some artifacts from the show um
yeah i don't know what i'm gonna do with
them i'm not really a collector so i
don't like put things out on display and
what are you saying uh i do like your
collection of things i i i as i was
looking at the baseballs on on your
shelf here yeah i got baseballs and
stuff it's just like you know i figured
i could have my office and a podcast
room where i could
you know these are kind of collectibles
and things like that and the rest of the
house is just kind of like nice i like
this i want you like this i want to have
my house look more like this you want a
studio with what are these what are
these bobble head things up here
uh the little bobble heads on the shelf
yeah um those are just like a collection
that i have i mean you know free [ __ ] or
like uh you know napoleon dynamite
hellraiser
christmas vacation uh
you know all that [ __ ] and then those i
have puppets those puppets that's a
princess leia puppet i got in i don't
know australia
that right that head right there is what
i wore in an episode of smallville it's
called onyx where i split in half good
luck bad lucks oh and i kept that it was
very uncomfortable
um
and yeah wow you know i auditioned for
that role
you auditioned for relax yeah yeah you
you beat me out oh my god yeah i don't
know how i i still it still amazes me
that i got that role it was it was a
lucky day man it was one of those days
isn't it isn't it interesting how one
little thing can change the course of
your life so radically you know it's
just like having that confidence for
that one moment in time
and they're like
that's the guy
and you're like what
i remember my friends going dude i
cannot see you as lex luthor are you
[ __ ] kidding me
i remember my friend matt
uh
when we came out we had lex luthor dolls
and we were i was having a little
gathering and everybody's laughing and
he turns around and he has the my doll
up his [ __ ]
yeah that just kind of put me into my
place
you know that put me
that's that's mad for it ballard you
[ __ ]
inside of you is brought to you by magic
spoon
ryan we love magic spoon why do we love
magic spoon uh because it is something
that uh it rekindles memories of
childhood but it does not uh hurt your
digestion
that is that is correct as a child we
have serious i won't say the cereals
names but we we eat them because they're
delicious and they taste sweet and it's
just it's just you know that's what we
like but as adults you're like oh this
is unhealthy for me i can't do this but
with magic spoon
you can you can go back to feeling like
a child again you can have these
delicious bowls of cereal uh you know
because cereal was one of the best parts
of growing up it really was um i had to
give it up because
it's obviously a lot of them are full of
sugar and junk that i really shouldn't
be eating we're all trying to eat better
but healthy breakfast doesn't have to be
boring magic spoon has the amazing
flavors you love but without all the bad
stuff and it's amazing as a midnight
snack right before bed you know we've
been trying to cut down on carbs sugar
and unhealthy food and realize that we
basically can't eat anything anymore
yeah no that's true i've been drinking
protein shakes you know um
powder for years but finally found a
delicious way to get my protein before
and after workouts and believe it or not
that is magic spoon i've had
demonstrations of the flavors here i've
had my friends eat the stuff it is
delicious you're not my friends have
text me go come on is this magic spoon
stuff for real it is for real i i love
it uh check this out uh zero grams of
sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein and only
four net grams of carbs in each serving
only 140 calories a serving it's keto
friendly gluten free grain free soy free
and low carb you build your own box
available flavors to build your own
custom bundles are cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter blueberry
cinnamon cookies and cream and maple
waffle
i don't know about you i love the
cinnamon i love the peanut butter
fruity
i do love the fruity uh this is easy
guys you gotta check this out uh go to
magicspoon.com
iou
to grab a custom bundle of cereal and be
sure to use our promo code iou at
checkout to save five dollars
off your order and magic spoon is so
confident in their product it's backed
with a 100 happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they'll
refund your money no questions asked
come on it's right there right there in
front of a magic spoon remember get your
next delicious bowl of guilt-free cereal
at magicspoon.com iou and use the code
iou to save five dollars off and thank
you
magic spoon for sponsoring this podcast
inside of you is brought to you by helix
sleep what do we do most in our lives
ryan
i would say sleep i would say sleep is
correct we do a lot of sleeping and if
you're not sleeping on a good mattress
something that you wake up refreshed you
were sleeping on the wrong freaking
mattress what i love about helix is they
have a quiz
it's easy i took it it takes moments out
of your life and it gets you connected
with the best mattress that's that's
right for you ultimately and uh we'll
talk about that in a second but look not
being able to sleep because of today's
politics pandemics your love life any
other drama uh that we can think of uh
you know these are these are big issues
in our world and if you're not getting a
good night's sleep with all the stress
and stuff that's around here i don't
know what you're doing helix sleep has a
quiz that takes just two minutes to
complete matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you why would you buy a
mattress made for someone else with
helix you're getting a mattress that you
know will be perfect for the way
you sleep
everybody's unique and helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium medium and firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot and even the helix plus
mattress for plus size sleepers i took
the helix quiz i was matched to of
course the medium mattress because you
know i wanted something somewhere in the
middle obviously like my porridge you
know what i'm talking about
um it's a huge upgrade to what i used to
have and uh you know my sleeping has
it's enhanced it's better and i i really
thank helix sleep for that it's been
awesome getting messages from so many of
you telling me how helix sleep has
changed your life how much you like the
helix mattress so thank you for sharing
those with me so if you're looking for a
mattress just take the quiz order the
mattress that you're matched to and the
mattress comes right to your door
shipped for free you don't ever need to
go to a mattress store again how
stressful i'm freaking mattress stores
they're stressful yes helix is awesome
but don't take my word for it helix was
awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 and by gq and
wired magazine just go to
helixsleep.com
inside take their two minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life that's true they have
a 10-year warranty and you can get i
think you get 100 nights yeah that's
what it is you get to try it out for 100
nights risk-free they'll even pick it up
for you if you don't love it but you
will helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixsleep.com
inside that's helix h-e-l-i-x sleep.com
inside for up to 200 off and two free
pillows inside of you is brought to you
by shopify i'll tell you my inside of
you online store has grown exponentially
and thanks to shopify they make it so
easy to have like a website of like
product that you can sell that's what
i'm calling it
shopify is i don't think there's anybody
else out there are there if there are i
don't know about them i don't want to
know about them shopify makes it easy it
gives entrepreneurs the resources once
reserved for big business so upstarts
startups and established businesses
alike can sell everywhere synchronize
online and in-person sales and
effortlessly stay informed scaling your
business is a journey of endless
possibility i also love that you can
connect with your customers
yeah you know figure out how to drive
sales manage your day to day it's all
right there it's all so easy to use if
you haven't used shopify and you're
thinking about selling something or you
know having a website full of items that
you think will sell this is the this is
the place to go shopify to me is the
only place that is is going to make it
easier for you and uh
you're going to know what you're selling
what sells what doesn't and uh you know
thank you shopify believe me this
podcast started out selling
very few things i had very few products
i didn't know what i was doing and when
i realized how easy it was
today we're doing really well people
it's easy to get to the store uh to the
shopify account and and order your
favorite things and uh i don't know what
i would do without them uh success is a
million milestones on a forever evolving
path like my shopify account shopify
powers millions of businesses from first
sale to full scale reach customers
online and across social networks with
an ever-growing suite of channel
integrations and apps including facebook
instagram tick tock pinterest and more
gain insights as you grow with detailed
reporting and conversion rates profit
margins and beyond i love putting in
well how much do they make from march
1st to april
10th whatever it is they go oh you made
this much money this is what your your
best selling product was
so you could see what works what doesn't
work it's all right there
right there in your shopify account uh i
love it i love shopify it's more than a
store shopify grows with you this is
possibility powered by shopify
go to shopify.com inside all lowercase
for a free 14-day trial and get full
access to shopify's entire suite of
features grow your business with shopify
today go to shopify.com
inside right now shopify.com
slash
inside
hey how was it working with larry k or
being on larry king's show that had to
be fun because i watched that interview
um
that that wasn't i think that was one of
those pinch me moments i just couldn't
believe i was sitting down and talking
to larry king you know he's uh
he was uh such an icon yeah for a good
reason he's
so easy to talk to yeah he said that
you misha had the most questions
ever asked on his show ever
for a
guest which is probably i mean he's had
a lot of huge
a-listers like you know
and he says that you
had the most questions are you blown
away by that yeah i was blown away by
that again that was early in the days of
social media right i think that was you
know probably a decade ago yeah
um and yet the supernatural fans had
already figured it out and we're already
you know online and active and you know
the likes of
oprah winfrey hadn't yet you know
developed an online uh social media
following so
yeah it's strange do you still get tons
of gifts from fans or have you said hey
guys please don't give me any gifts
spend that money and donate to like my
charity or something like that do you
ever oh god i would never say something
like that
would never say something so selfless is
that
it's fun it's funny i went uh i did a
convention in japan and uh have you ever
been to no i don't i don't know if
smallville would be big there but it was
such a funny experience because it was
like uh everyone who came up to the to
the autograph table
brought a gift right and um
and i
and i guess it was just it's just a
cultural thing like you're visiting our
country here's a gift
and i i kept on just grabbing the thing
and setting it down next to me and uh
and then
some one of the uh
uh assistants at the convention said
where would you like the stuff all the
gifts and i said oh i don't know just
bring it up to my hotel room and i got
to my hotel room and i couldn't open the
door to my hotel room it was
they had literally filled up the entire
room with gifts and it was it was quite
fun going through it all i had my kids
you went through it all i went through
it all and i had my kids with me and it
was christmas time like it was right
before christmas so i was like kids this
is christmas so we went through this
mountain of gifts from some really great
kids some really great like there were
some gopros and things like that in
there but never been a gopro but the
amazing thing it was then the next year
at christmas that my kids were young at
the point at that point they were like
dad can't wait for christmas and all the
gifts and i was like oh no no no no no
that's not how it's going to be that was
just a one-off kids so now they're
forever disappointed with the holidays
wow and so you don't just say you know
hey i thank you for all the gifts but
you really don't because you probably
get gifts every convention you go to
you'll go to texas and you'll get tons
of [ __ ] right
um yeah although uh
i think over yeah i don't know i don't
know yeah the conventions now do tell
people not to give gifts so we don't get
we don't get that i got much stuff this
my friend lee and kristen made me a a
pillow with every guest i've had on the
podcast oh well that's very sweet isn't
that nice
i think i just have my 200th oh my god
it's a lot yeah it's a lot of people
like i never thought i would be doing
this either i just was like i i can't do
this i'm not no who wants to listen to
me and most people don't
but um
are you talking who are you talking to
primarily i i don't listen to your show
on the regular i just listen to to when
i'm on it um who do i what uh who who do
you interview is it is it other actors
you know anywhere from like bob odenkirk
to to kiefer sutherland to uh
jennifer love hewitt jensen was just
about mostly mostly actors directors
that kind of thing um occasionally i'll
have an athlete on or a rocker you know
i had richard marks on who's a friend
you know so it's fun it's fun to kind of
you know
talk to these to these folks and get to
know them but you know
i
as much as like you know in passing hey
misha yeah i kind of know misha through
right you know we've seen each other but
to me this is pretty cool because you
throw on some headphones and for an hour
i learn a lot about you you know i get
to know you a little bit more and like
you know it's it's
it's not an opportunity for me to really
listen because i'm it's hard for me to
listen mm-hmm if you take these
headphones off and we're out there i
mean i'll listen to you but i'll
sometimes i'm a scatter brain a little
add but this forces you to kind of just
like yeah zone in
i just did this um
uh
series for pbs called road food yeah
jensen said to ask you about that we
traveled around the country
um
talking to
i mean honestly we're using food as a as
a window in the world so we're looking
at little you know regional dishes
uh you know gumbo in louisiana for
example and we're using that as a window
into worlds where we'll i'll sit down
and literally break bread with people
and talk to them about their lives and
world
but it was actually really fascinating
because it was an excuse like you're
saying an excuse to sit down and listen
to people and talk to people and get to
know them that i wouldn't otherwise have
sat down with there just wouldn't have
been occasion but i also wouldn't have i
just wouldn't have made the space and
time for it yeah and so when you slow
down and you give some time and
attention and you actually let yourself
be present with someone it's kind of
remarkable like i
gleaned these little pearls of life
wisdom from
the guy who ran the little tortilla
factory sure brownsville texas
um or you know or or the mayor of
tangier island in in the chesapeake bay
all of these individuals that i would
never have talked to
um were willing
to just open up and it was lovely it was
really fascinating i actually feel like
i learned about the human family through
that experience that's amazing and i
feel i feel the same way i think you
nailed it i think you know sitting with
someone there's like little morsels
little things that you've said little
things that other guests have said which
sort of help me or they help other
people who are listening
it's just like
a candid conversation open and i kind of
just you know throw [ __ ] at you and i i
find it to be fun i i i was going to
quit many times
the first 10 interviews i was like
nobody's listening nobody's listening
15.
you know 30 guests in i'm just like what
am i doing no one wants to hear me
interview people and then all of a
sudden i stuck with it and i started to
get more vulnerable and i think that's
when the show
got better when i started to open up and
i started to talk about my imperfections
which are
i have
many and i think that's you know people
kind of like that i open up like that
and you know even you you open up again
about your divorce and all the [ __ ]
you're going through and it's like wow
it's uh you know it's not all about
fluff and all about what you're doing
next and you know it's uh i don't know i
find it interesting to see that you know
we all go through ruts we all go through
tough times
you know
yeah i um that kind of reminds me of
when i when i first got on supernatural
and for you know the cw was knocking and
saying we need you to come do some
interviews
and i my at that at that time my wife
was in
graduate school she was getting her phd
in pop culture history and her advisor
uh had just written a biography of
marilyn monroe and marilyn monroe had
been one of these early starlets who had
totally cultivated her public persona so
everything about her was cultivated
the color of her hair the shape of her
nose the timber of her voice everything
was cultivated and based on what the
the a-listers of the time were looking
like and sounding like and how they were
walking and talking so
i thought well maybe this is my
opportunity to cultivate my public
persona this is the first time i'm
getting in you know doing interviews
it's the first time i'm getting in front
of cameras and talking about myself
misha in quotes right i can present
however i want i can present as the
ideal version of american masculinity
and we started i started doing
interviews and had this idea of of a
version of myself that i wanted to to
have the public see and it was
stiff
and awkward and uncomfortable
and
not at all charming
and i suddenly realized i can't do this
like i if i do this
i'm going to quit this job all together
i i hate you not being authentic and so
i just started bearing it all and i was
like oh okay that's that's that's that's
how it's gonna have to be for me well
it's worked um it's worked for you yeah
i suppose i suppose it's work you know
you said that you you don't really feel
like you fit in
you said that before
because i always feel like that too i
always feel like when i'm around other
celebrities or at a party i'm just like
i just don't feel like i fit in and i
could pretend to fit in is that what
you're saying in a way or do you
just not like to be around
big celebrity parties and and not that i
go to a party especially now in the last
two years but what is it what do you
mean exactly you say you don't feel like
you fit in
well i don't know i mean i'm not sure
what
what
context that
statement was made in but i know that i
felt that way when i was growing up um i
was
you know my
my family
was homeless at times and we were moving
constantly when i was a kid i lived in
15 different places by the time i was
in uh high school
and
uh was in a new school every year and
that uh that all of those factors
combined to make me always an outsider
in school and
i didn't have a friend group and so i
was always i was i really actually
didn't fit in and i was also not
terribly well socialized we didn't have
a television
my mom kind of dressed me as a girl so i
would you know
sure i remember you talking about that
in the last podcast yeah yeah so i'm
rehashing i like rehashes i like it no i
like that but but long story short i
just i i always kind of felt like an
outsider and i and i felt like i had to
figure out some tricks to ingratiate
myself to social groups so i i relied on
self-deprecating humor that was
something that i used a lot of in high
school and i found that i people were
like oh that's kind of charming they'd
laugh at it and at some point i realized
i have to stop
doing all of this self-deprecating humor
because i'm putting myself down so much
that i'm starting to feel bad about
myself wow um
but
when i
i and it still shows up in some places
i'm sure i've done a lot of therapy and
work on like early childhood trauma and
realized that
you know i actually was traumatized in a
locker room when i was really young so
when i go into locker rooms even now as
an adult i feel uncomfortable and that
played out in in high school and college
like i didn't really want to be involved
in organized sports
because i didn't want to be in locker
rooms and i didn't even realize that was
happening you know but i was like this
this isn't i don't fit in here right so
as i get older i'm starting to find that
i'm a little bit more comfortable in my
own skin like i feel like i fit in
inside me if you know to yeah plagiarize
your podcast uh title
um but i
but you know as i'm getting more
comfortable in my skin i think i'm a
little bit less
concerned with whether or not i quote
fit in or not and i'm and i'm more okay
being whatever kind of peripheral
outsider i am
and
and as a consequence i do feel more
comfortable in you know most social
situations now i'm not as like i'm not
watching myself to figure out whether or
not people are okay with how i'm
behaving yeah am i cool enough am i i
don't remember fitting it you don't
really give a [ __ ] i care it's taken
it's taken years though to probably get
there yeah right yeah i used to i used
to run things over in my head a lot like
oh did what did they think of me you
know did i embarrass myself right and
now i can do something embarrassing and
be like well that was stupid
and then move on and move on
uh jared padalecki was texting me this
morning what an [ __ ] he said he said
uh see if he's willing to tell you about
the fart on the plane story
okay uh yeah sure let's do it let's
let's do my fart story what is it so um
i i don't know how long your your
podcast can run but this is a long is it
what can we
nope it has to be incredibly long
so
um all right i i was uh i was flying um
from los angeles to boston on jetblue
and stopped off before the flight to
have dinner with
my wife's mother and
my wife and i were vegetarians at the
time and she took us to p.f chang's
china bistro and we had no money at this
point and so we gorged
on every vegetarian entree they had at
pf chang's there's a lot of roasted
garlic in everything it seemed like and
that's something that doesn't
necessarily agree with my system
we got on the flight
and i was it was a packed flight and i
was sitting in a middle seat
and about half hour into the flight i
felt like the pressure building up oh my
god i've got to let i've got i've got to
fart but i didn't want to like excuse me
sorry get up get up go to the bathroom i
was just gonna let it so i decided what
i would do is just let it out a little
bit at a time
so that it would dissipate and not be a
big deal and you know on the plane when
you fart it's like no one can hear it
nobody can hear because there's the
sound of the jet engine it's gonna be
fine yeah so anyway i i
endeavored to let it out a little bit at
once but unfortunately when i don't
pressure change or something it all came
out at once
and
just the fart
just just the fart came out and uh
and there's a guy sitting behind me
um who fainted
from your fart
yeah and his uh his girlfriend called
the flight attendants over and said
uh mike you know he's pat they they came
they administered oxygen they
resuscitated him and she said somebody
somebody has gas
and the flight attendant said no no
ma'am that's not possible uh all of the
all of the fuel is stored on the wings
there's nothing none of the none of you
the fuel could come into the fuselage at
all it's not possible and so they all
let it go i i fell asleep i i woke up uh
it was about an hour later and i had to
fart again and i thought i'll just just
a little bit at a time again i farted
again the guy faints again they
administer oxygen
and again his girlfriend says somebody
has gas and the flight attendant again
ma'am that's not possible it's all
you're hearing all this 100 i'm hearing
it all i'm like slinking down into the
seat i'm absolutely mortified and the
woman sitting next to them in that in
the row said so they say no ma'am it's
not possible for there to be a gas leak
and the woman says ah it's not a gas
leak somebody has to go to the bathroom
and so we land the plane and everyone
has to sit in their seats while
paramedics come and get this guy off the
plane and shoot your pants he's saying
as he's saying it's never happened to me
before i i don't know it's just
something smells so bad
oh
my god
anyway that is superb so i don't know
what your sponsorship relationship is i
love
china
but if pf chang's isn't paying you they
should be all right that was an
unbelievable story because you know you
know how much i love farts ryan uh and
lastly he said the story of kayaking in
palau
oh huh i don't really know if there's
much of us all right well
yeah all right yeah all right this is la
the last thing is [ __ ] talking with uh
misha collins this is my these are my
patrons
they give back to the show
they get to ask questions it's rapid
fire oh if you will
and that's it
lisa h just lit a little bit out is what
he's saying yeah yeah
just yeah just a little just a little
that's amazing
that's amazing that someone fainted from
your ass yeah it's a it's sad but true
ah it's like a metallica song lisa h
during the filming of supernatural when
cass and dean were watching porn what
was really on the screen porn something
else or nothing my husband wants to know
because your expressions were priceless
in that particular instance there was it
was just lights on the screen um that
that were flickering uh and very
carefully cultivated to make it look
like i was watching television um
however i will tell you that um in the
show there's a recurring motif
that
that dean likes
this magazine called busty asian
beauties so he's always picking up a cop
a copy of busty asian beauties and i
went there was a an episode where my
character was in a convenience store
shopping and there they had on the of
course on the magazine rack were copies
of busty asian beauty beauties and i
picked one up and it's
you know it's a porn magazine and i
picked it up and i opened it expecting
to find it yeah you know it to be a a
an entertainment weekly magazine or
something and i open it up and sure
enough it was
it was a magazine called barely 18. and
it's an actual porn magazine that the
that the set dressers had thought you
know what we'll be funny we'll we'll put
this fake cover on an actual oh my god
so i picked it up and i was like oh my
god what am i looking at so
um so sometimes there was porn on the
set of supernatural but it was mostly
just the set dressers oh i love that
that's good they'd probably get in
trouble for that didn't they uh they
will now they will now years later
leanne
what is something people would be
surprised to learn about you
besides that you're a poet you have a
book published new york times best list
is that correct yeah [ __ ] dude yeah yep
i got new york times best-selling poetry
book which is i think not a lot of
people could say that because not a lot
of books of poetry sell um i was pretty
excited about that
um i am
i would say that
i i
consider myself an introvert
i don't think a lot of people
know that or would say that about me i
could see that um but i'm fairly
introverted hmm
are you sort of quiet at home
you sort of like in your own head you
kind of
you know no you're not very animated no
that i can be animated and boisterous
but i also have a tendency to want to
recharge on my own so
you know i don't spend a lot of time
hanging out in the green room
right you don't care about other actors
and talking to them
precisely yes
i know nancy d well now that you're a
new york times best-selling poet can we
expect a follow-up collection
i don't know but that is a um uh it's
something that i'm percolating on to to
recycle a word from earlier in the
podcast
um i
uh i i wrote my book of poetry over the
course of like 20 years and um
and
definitely was not thinking of a
follow-up volume
uh but it has been well received and i
don't know maybe maybe i'm starting to
write again so we'll see i like it robin
asks how much weight did you gain during
the taping of road food
i
am
shocked to announce that i just went to
the doctors and i had high cholesterol
and now i have moderately high
cholesterol which is slightly less
cholesterol
moderately and and road food was a lot
of greasy and fried food so i don't know
what happened but somehow somehow i got
healthier over the course of it
you got healthy healthier over the
course of it yeah i don't know what
happened i can't explain it
that's amazing what was the best thing
you ate on the road i'm curious
um i i liked the viet cajun crawfish it
was pretty delicious
yeah i'm allergic to that are you i
think i'm allergic to shrimp so yeah
you're not gonna have crawfish for sure
or not yeah
i miss it what makes it be it well what
was it it was like it was a combination
of spices it was like cajun cajun
crawfish but then they infused it with
some vietnamese spices and sauces that
were some hungry secrets
you wouldn't tell me what it was
uh yvore what is the most memorable
memorable day of your life that's that's
a tough one
the most memorable day of your life why
don't we say besides your children being
born
i uh they're they're certainly i don't
even know how to quantify most memorable
um
i i don't have a certain day that i
rehash in my mind more than others i'm
not someone who
spends a lot of time reflecting on the
past
um
i
i have for some reason i'm just gonna
randomly select a memory that's popping
out for me i remember when i was um four
years old i was sitting on this uh horse
fence
and a tractor came down the road in
front of the fence
and i remember thinking
well
uh that's it i've seen a tractor so many
times now that this is no longer
interesting
three years old was the best age
from now on it's all downhill
and i
i very i have this very distinct
recollection of that
framing of new experiences when i was
four years old so that is memorable
wow yep that was my i was the moment
that i realized that i had peaked
yes
laura w if you hadn't gone down the path
of acting what do you think you would
have ended up doing i'm gonna guess
politics
you know it's interesting i thought i
was gonna go into politics and then i
course corrected somewhere along the
lines and i
actually think i would have been an
artist of some sort i'm not sure if if i
would have been a visual artist or a
performance artist or
um i mean i i i've been working on some
large-scale public art installations and
that has been really gratifying but also
you know writing poetry or writing in
general
i feel like i need to be expressing some
sort of creative energy or else i'm not
i'm not doing what i'm supposed to be
doing yeah so something creative
i could see that
abel f what dish is taking you to a
euphoric place
versus a dish so bad you couldn't
swallow and had to tell the cook no
um
there i i have a very fond childhood um
affinity for
japanese uh dumplings um that my friend
used to make
and
so it's like that's that's kind of a
comfort food for me
um
i was in iceland and i tried the
fermented shark
have you have you seen this delicacy no
um so they take a shark and they bury it
in the sand and then the uh shark starts
to decompose and eventually the bladder
that's filled with shark urine breaks
and the urine helps preserve the
remaining rotting flesh
so it's fermented urine soaked
shark meat
and it tastes even worse than it sounds
it was like putrid it was putrid and
unfathomable that someone would eat this
were they insulted
when you
no
i think that not many outsiders are able
to eat this food
wow did you want to throw up yes i did
and i i'm still i'm not this is not an
exaggeration i'm still getting like
goosebumps thinking about that that
flavor it was
really shutter worthy wow what's what do
you love the most in terms of food like
what's something that you just you just
can feel it coming down your throat
just you know what i mean like say that
again no i don't want to i don't want to
but something that you're just like i
just want like right now
i'm i love bolognese
i love that with some garlic bread
but yeah what about you i
uh
i love i love fresh produce it's funny
having to i'm not having just on this
show road food which is like it's we're
delving into um regional
american cuisine but it's not like fancy
stuff it's it's the stuff that you find
at roadside diners right
and it's very heavy and it's very salty
and it's very greasy and it's very
bacon-laden
and uh having finished that show i'm
like i want i want a fresh tomato
with maybe a salt shaker and that's it
you know
um
yeah are you are you one to drink sodas
and
are you pretty healthy i'm pretty
healthy salads you lot of salad right
because i just started that for the new
year more salads no sodas no cookies no
chips at night
less popcorn
trying to eat healthy i'm glad that you
haven't cut the popcorn out all together
yeah i've had popcorn twice this year
and uh
but you know you got to have some vice
i've quit a lot of vices i stopped this
vaping [ __ ] oh you were vaping i was
vaping a lot occasional smoking and i'm
like what are you doing my grandfather
way back when he used to smoke or used
to smoke and my uncle dave was sitting
him in the car sitting with him in the
car
and
back then you just smoked in the car
with the kids you know you didn't give a
[ __ ] my my grandfather of smoking and my
uncle dave looks at him that's his dad
and goes
why do you smoke
and he looked at dave and goes
i don't know
and he quit that day he had no reason he
had no answer for him
he goes i don't that's amazing i don't
know
and he just quit
and i always found that to be pretty
cool because really that's what i think
of him like why are you doing this well
i'm a little stressed i'm a little stop
it
this isn't helping you
you know so i'm trying to do that more
and
it's
it's not always easy no you know the
addictive uh part of our brains will
will give you that little kick like
right now it would be right now it would
be nice it would and it would be nice
right now but if you can keep the
perspective to remember that in the long
run it's going to kill me in the long
run it's not good if i do it right now
i'm going to want to do it again
five hours from now yeah
um
yeah that's something i think probably
all of us struggle with and some yeah we
all have vices we all have that one
thing that we're like [ __ ]
yeah i'm not a drinker i'm not really a
smoker i've been getting into these
pot taffys
they're just like low milligram taffys
with a little pot that i'll take at
night
and i've been taking those a little bit
but now i'm like wait a minute are you
taking these every night now what the
[ __ ] dude this is your next vice
all right so you say you're working on
you right now you're taking some time
off you're just you're not
in the middle of working on something
right now right now it's taking care of
misha time yeah that's right well that
sounds good yeah you can continue that
for a little while until you're ready
for the next step yeah i think you can
do this out well it's cw money in your
bank there's a a poet
rainier maria rilke from uh he's a
19th century german poet
and he there's a quote of his that i
really love which is everything is
gestation and birth
and i think that that's really true for
creative people but we have to give
ourselves time to gestate just give
ourselves that space to allow
the thing to to grow to percolate up to
percolate the word of the podcast
uh i really thank you for coming over
this has been a real treat for me
and uh you know i we we have i haven't
seen you in person i don't know how long
yeah it's been five years it's been a
long time yeah and uh
i always learn something you're a smart
guy you're open you're
uh you're one of the good ones well
thanks for having me back it's really
nice to see your space in person it's
good to be here and uh yeah yeah ryan
you want to say anything to uh mish oh
real quick bob garfield 67. he's 67. 67.
he's like did i say 65.
you didn't say 65 yeah i was pretty
close i had to google it but you know he
looks much younger than 67.
did dr seuss write you a poem no he
didn't damn yeah i wish that would have
been cool i also wish i still had the
signed photo when i lost it somewhere
damn it
all right all right take care i love you
bye
you know what was great it was him
talking about these stories you know the
farting on the plane one of my favorites
oh that was a good story you know any
any time we talk about farts in a plane
you love a good fart i'd rather farts in
a plane than snakes
you know i mean if you're gonna ask me i
mean i think an ultimate nightmare would
be farting snakes
farting snakes on the right
brutal
with their
thank you misha for being on the podcast
again i appreciate it again if you liked
misha and you like the podcast and
you're like hey i like the interview
listen to the podcast next week you
might learn something the guests are
always forthcoming and open and honest
and i feel like people learn things so i
i appreciate everybody who listens to
the podcast every week and those that
don't if you're here for misha again
hopefully you'll stick around next week
also join patreon if you want to support
the podcast keep it going without the
patrons i don't think i could do this
podcast patreon.com inside of you i'll
write a message right after also the
inside of you online store uh great
merch tons of smallville stuff tons of
inside of you merch and if you want to
go to sunspin.com my band is sun spin
you could book me for a zoom i could buy
sun spin sweet swag
sweet swag
hats shirts whatnot uh
and uh what else you could also oh make
sure you follow us on all the handles
and what are those handles again ryan at
inside if you caught on twitter inside
of you podcast on instagram and facebook
that is absolutely correct and please
leave a review you don't know how much
it helps to leave a review spotify apple
youtube subscribe everywhere support the
pod that's all i'm going to say i
appreciate everybody today and my top
tier
patrons
um
you know these these are the folks that
i'm about to read their name this is one
of the perks where i read off their name
at the end of every podcast
and they really helped the podcast in so
many ways they give back so thank you to
all these people here we go nancy d leah
s sarah v little lisa yukiko jill e
brian h nico p robert b jason w kristen
k amelia oh allison l raj c joshua d cjp
jennifer n stacy l jen asked jamal f
janelle b kimberly e mike e l don
99 more ramirez san diego m chad w
leanne p janine r
maya p maddie s belinda n correct chris
h dave h spider-man chase sheila g brad
d ray h tabitha t tom and liliana a
talia m betsy d chat l rochelle marion
meg k trav l dan n big stevie w angel m
rhiannon c corey k super sam dev next
and michelle a jeremy c andy t cody r
gavin nader
david c john b brandy d
yvore camille
camille
don't know that i don't know take a
guess
take a guess
s correct
the
c correct joey m willie f adelaide n
omar i lena n design otg design otg
eugene and leah chris p corey patricia
heather l jake b james b bobbitt eddie
ed a
ebola f
joshua b tony g sean r megan t mel s
orlando c john b caroline r darren b rob
e paul c christine h
christine s
christine s
sarah s
and eric
h
without these folks i don't know what
the podcast would do we'd suffer
we uh love all your help all your um
positivity and your support
so patreon.com inside of you
thank you everyone a lot of great stuff
going on stuff that i can't really talk
about just yet but soon
we're working on a new project
and you guys will hear about it probably
in the next month i'd say
probably in the next month
and uh ryan's working on it with us and
um
it's exciting it's exciting it's it's
new it's gonna be a work in progress so
you know hopefully uh
hopefully you're gonna dig things
that's all i could say really uh you
have anything else ryan
uh no that's a good um good teaser
that's a good teaser isn't it it sure is
i'm headed to arkansas actually when you
hear this i'll already be back from
arkansas but my next cons are going to
be uh
st louis liverpool
australia
um
illinois at the metropolis festival or
something the uh metropolis illinois tom
and i are gonna do uh smallville nights
we're gonna do small nights i believe in
st louis
um i believe in i don't know if the
liverpool are gonna do it but we're
gonna do in australia so a lot of great
stuff coming up hopefully you guys would
join me come to the uh
come to the cons see us hug it out
and uh that's all i really have to say
and uh also follow me at the michael
rosenbaum and i'm on the cameo too if
you want to if you want to cameo me
he can wish you a happy birthday
yeah my birthday's coming up i would say
you could wish people a happy birthday
oh i can't wait oh that's right that's
right there's several months before that
birthday that's true i have
that's a big one though guys i'm gonna
be 50 i can't even believe it i don't
believe it either i don't i can't
believe it anyway thank you for
listening to the podcast thanks for
being here thanks to ryan from uh
michael rosenbaum here in the hollywood
hills of california i'm ryan hayes and
i'll give the camera a little wave
thanks for supporting this podcast thank
you and uh
have a good week
be good to yourselves that's the most
important thing i think is just be good
to yourself we all uh we're all [ __ ]
right we're all [ __ ] just uh trying
to get by that's right so dude that's
our bumper sticker we're all [ __ ]
just trying you know
i mean
i'll tell you we're all [ __ ] just
trying to get by
it's it's kind of true i mean it's you
know it's like every day is a
do you think every day is a grind ryan
yeah
yeah it shouldn't be though right it
shouldn't be but it has been
it has been maybe it's the whole covet
thing for a couple years and now we're
getting out of it and
you know but like yeah i just need i
need to get out of my house more i need
to i'm starting to do that i'm playing a
little tennis i'm starting to play a
little hockey again i'm trying to golf a
little bit i'm trying to get out of the
house trying to enjoy my friends
and uh just uh stay positive and not
get so absorbed in my [ __ ] just trying
to get by with your [ __ ]
we're all [ __ ] just trying to get by
uh all my love to you we'll talk to you
next week
[Music]
you